it was over the old guard was wiped out  those who Neal were now at the gates of  hell they were killing us off burning  our seas from shore to shore we thought  there was no way the Empire could win  this game  as fate would have it the tide turned in  our favor again a new wind will set our  backs blowing us straight to heaven  in our New Eden there was only one rule  first comment that fuss  [Music]  it was dog eat dog  we became kings queens and masters of  our new worlds fortunes poured down on  us they are their empire now it was our  turn enemies became friends friends  became enemies the best didn't trust  anybody the philosophy of the day was  and more we were alone at the top of the  food chain  [Music]  well we so we left  [Music]  in a dog-eat-dog world  we were wolves  the moves hunt in packs  [Music]  [Music]  you  you